la chine est devenue au cours des 25
dernières années
la manufacture de la plaine vêtements
informatique électronique dans cette
usine située à 150 km de pékin
on fabrique 70 différentes pièces à base
de plastique
vous reconnaissez peut-être cette
bouteille si la saveur canadienne
explique avec le sourire le patronat est
donc bien en donnant aux journaux de la
crise dans l'industrie pétrolière arrive
comme un cadeau du ciel pour cette
entreprise
la production de chacune de ces pièces
de plastique nécessitent une grande
quantité de pétrole
les économies depuis six mois se chiffre
en dizaines de milliers de dollars
il en a produit entre honneurs avec la
baisse du prix du brut indique-t-il
le coût de revient d'une pièce comme
celle ci a diminué de 20%
une différence cruciale pour les
entreprises chinoises qui ont du mal à
soutenir la hausse de leurs exportations
la croissance économique dans le pays
devrait être de -10 7% cette année la
plus basse en 30 ans
mais en plus d'épargnants des milliards
en coûts de production la chaîne profite
aussi du faible prix du pétrole sur les
marchés internationaux pour augmenter
ses réserves stratégiques
en fait elles veulent et doublé en un an
c'est pourquoi les ports et raffineries
tournent à fond comme ici à ningbo sur
la côte est chinoise
le pays importe en ce moment plus de
pétrole que n'importe qui d'autre sur la
planète
l'effondrement des prix devrait faire
économiser à la chine 70 milliards de
dollars américains cette année selon la
banque merrill lynch
et les avantages ne s'arrêtent pas là le
géant asiatique veut aussi profiter de
cette occasion pour s'attaquer à l'un de
ses principaux problèmes
environnementaux
la pollution de l'air en raison de son
insatiable soif énergétique la chaîne
brûle aujourd'hui cinquante deux pour
cent de tout le charbon qui est
consommée sur la plaine
autrefois lorsque pékin voulait
effectuer des réformes se débarrasser du
charbon explique cet expert en énergie
le prix du gaz naturel ne cessait de
grimper
cette fois ci les astres sont alignés
pour que le gouvernement effectue la
transition mais les batteries l'or noir
n'arriveront pas à solutionner tous les
problèmes en chine personne ne sait
combien de temps dureront les aubaines
sur le ddt heureux dans ce contexte le
patron de pao chaîne a choisi avec son
ingénieur de réinvestir tout l'argent
qu'ils économisent pour diversifier sa
gamme de produits il veut doubler son
chiffre d'affaires d'ici cinq ans
la crise dans l'industrie pétrolière
pourrait devenir son plus grand allié
pour qu'il atteigne sombre ici van kote
radio-canada tianjin